[Music]
now
[Music]
a long time that glasses are going to be
an important part of building the next
computing platform and unlocking a whole
new set of experiences for people see so
i'm excited that today
that's exactly what the robot dog looked
like his eyes his facial expressions
yeah
damn why we are very excited how do you
release glasses what does mark look like
a hundred years older i don't know it's
weird right yeah it didn't look right
good so
he's not aging like a human
so
facebook released their version of
google glass remember that yeah and
they're like ray-bans okay no it's more
like snap glasses okay and they're like
cam they're ray-bans with cameras in
them so i'm working on with estellar
luxottica
we wanted to build something that would
enable you to easily capture and share
experiences from your point of view and
we thought if we're gonna build
best-in-class classes a great place to
start is with the iconic ray-ban frames
that people already love so i'm proud to
introduce to you
ray-ban stories
[Music]
with ray-ban stories you can capture
photos and videos listen to music or
podcasts or take phone calls all while
staying in the moment and without even
taking out your phone whether you're on
a hike cooking or just hanging out or
playing outside with your kids you're
gonna be able to quickly capture that
experience and share it if you want to
and this is just the start ray-ban
stories are an important step towards a
future when phones are no longer a
central part of our lives
why does it why does he look like he's
never front of the glasses deposit he
looks like he's never worn sunglasses
yeah in his entire life he's like he why
is he sitting so unnaturally so he's
like and yeah it's just like normal you
can go hiking
and you can it's like a dog trying to
get like something no you put like
something weird on a dog and he's like
he's moving all weird
he like neutralized him he like put it
on and doesn't want to move his head now
he's like it's like
well these fall off
these i don't want to move too fast mark
they're they're size for your head it's
totally fine you hand glasses you have
ears they're hooked onto the back of
your ears and he's like
they're like he forgot
lizard tongue comes out he just eats
them yeah oh mark that's the fourth
[ __ ] pair
can we find some more sunglasses for
mark please
two five megapixel cameras okay what
else we got two five megapixel cameras
built-in you can activate the camera
with the push of a button on the side of
the frame a tap starts recording a video
or you can tap and hold it to take a
photo or you can just say hey facebook
take a video for a hands-free experience
yeah that's sick that's [ __ ] awesome
i can't imagine we also built and say
discreet open your speakers take a video
on the side of the frames to let you
take calls
music or podcasts you're in a bathroom
you're in the stalling you just hear hey
facebook take a video
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
no dude you're just at a bar with your
friends hey facebook
hey hey facebook no not you shut the
[ __ ] up stop looking at me hey facebook
take a video i'm talking to my ray-bans
god damn it hold on they're not [ __ ]
working
[Laughter]
just
during sex
don't you [ __ ] dare okay just it was
it's in the moment hey facebook take a
video is the new i'm recording you yeah
it is
any any altercation i was gonna say hey
facebook take a video all this [ __ ] is
gonna be is capital riot like live
streams i know that's what i'm saying
it's just this is just
like
it's just like snitch where yeah you
know annoying people
yeah
i'm here protesting pronouns because i
don't want pronouns to be a requirement
of my child's curriculum just like in
[ __ ] somewhere in nebraska
okay
yeah i mean it's just anyone who like
gets into any sort of altercation their
first prompt is to do this oh it's gonna
be the ultimate it's gonna be that
person's ultimate tool
we should reboot everything we should
reboot robocop but it's just
yeah it's just moms with the facebook
glasses walking around capturing crime
yeah hey sorry i don't i don't have
enough change to pay you in cash can you
just pay in card instead
um i'm sorry what hey facebook take a
video
this man says he doesn't have enough
cash you're a business aren't you
i'm paying in cash can i
yes but it's 20 42 and we haven't used
cash for the last five years so we can't
take cash anymore
uh facebook go live
broadcast just here we go
here we [ __ ] go
like
arming like
the worst people with the most invasive
technology like
not even like some like aegis [ __ ] but
what do you you want a bunch of 50 year
olds walking around like just screaming
hey facebook take a video
we'll be doing that for all kinds of
stupid [ __ ]
all your grandparents feeds just gonna
be like videos of like birds and the
sidewalk and
meals and
just two and a half second videos of a
random portion of the sidewalk
as they're walking
is a bike flipping over
oh my grandpa went on a bike ride let's
check this one out
two oh [ __ ]
next video is inside of an ambulance
oh
sorry
nice dude sorry
we put this led light on the front of
the glasses so that people around you
will know when you're taking a photo or
video it lights up to let people know
that the camera is on and that's more
than what smartphones do there's also a
power switch to turn off your glasses
whenever you want like if you're in a
private space
when your glasses are off they are
completely off when your glasses are off
they are completely off
mic is off and you can't take photos or
record videos
we will still be looking at them though
yeah i just love how he's
really trying to sell it we are
definitely not recording
they are completely off we're not
tracking anything
completely off
when they're off that means they're off
and there's an off switch here to turn
them off
and if you do that they'll be completely
off
i will say this is like allowing for the
fantasy of xbox recording
that'll be off
mark i turned my glasses off why are
pictures of my feet in my
toilet and
my dick and balls all over my facebook
timeline
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] is there some phrase that's
close to facebook take a video
um facebook take a video
for take a video
nevermind it'd be so funny if there was
some like commonly said phrase that's
pretty close to that people are like
accidentally turning it on oh like like
almost like a hey siri yeah yeah exactly
yeah
and uh they did choose the most
difficult way to turn it on
unfortunately it's not like a hey alexa
yeah
so funny to see
are those those new uh facebook yeah
they are hey facebook take a video no no
stop stop what the [ __ ] dude
yeah just pranking them
you see like a group of people with it
hey facebook take a video all night oh
hey
come on
hey facebook go live
or you bro it's on an old ass person
you're like hey facebook go live and you
see the light turn red and they're just
sitting there like
[Laughter]
you're just like
i wonder where it's going live to
i don't know but he's live dude
what should we do
i don't know dude
walk in front of him like just fart or
something
you think they heard that
[Laughter]
just like sitting there just with their
cane and [ __ ] just bright red
you're just sitting looking back like
[Music]
if facebook go live
damn
yeah that's gonna be the prank